[Music]
foreign
Pages as they arrive it's time to see
what's making the headlines with the
spectators political editor Katie balls
and the broadcaster and commentator Alex
Andro they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
the Metro leads with the government
taking its own covert inquiry to court
over the disclosure of Boris Johnson's
WhatsApp messages
the guardian says people who lost loved
ones to the pandemic have condemned the
move
the financial times points out that Mr
Johnson has in fact only handed over
messages from May 2021 onwards when he
acquired a new phone
it's also the top story for the eye
the covert inquiry also covers the front
of the times at this time with the
headline battle over Johnson messages
and ministers go to war with judge over
covid whatsapps reads the front of the
Daily Mirror as they too lead with the
same story
the sun speaks directly to Philip
Schofield who denies he groomed the
young colleague with whom he had an
affair while working on this morning
The Daily Mirror also leads with an
exclusive from a presenter on this
morning this time however it's from
Holly with the headline I've nothing to
hide
and the front of the star looks at how
the cost of living has affected our fish
and chip shops
there you are a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us and we are
joined tonight by Katie balls and Alex
Andrew welcome to you both let's start
with the sun and this exclusive
interview that they have with Philip
Schofield
um the first time that he's um spoken
out aside from his um messages and
tweets Etc on social media Katie takes
into this
yes so as you say exclusive interview
comes after uh Philip Schofield of
course uh stepped down pushed out
um and ultimately runs with a headline
I'm broken and ashamed but not a groomer
and Philip Schofield is using this
interview I think to fight back you
could say from some of the press
coverage some of the claims by some of
his former colleagues some Anonymous in
recent days to try and set the record
straight he is acknowledging as he has
in written statements and that he did
have a relationship with a younger male
colleague and but he is saying that this
does not count as grooming and he is
also saying that he regrets it but this
is an isolated mistake and he doesn't
recognize some of the things that are
being said about him now of course uh
there's lots of book hands right now and
I think the question is how seriously or
how much people trust what Philip
Schofield says at this point and what
implications does it have in terms of
the the rolling consequence of this in
terms of not just Phillip Schofield
um the the man who's involved with
Philip Schofield but also the future of
of the breakfast show and because there
are some saying how can it really go on
our management going to have to go who
knew what when and I think this is where
the story is now going
yes the the paper reporting that um
Phillip Schofield has been hiding since
um uh what they described as the Scandal
broke um Alex but now as as Katie says
uh really that the story of potentially
turning to the duty of care that ITV had
towards the the male colleague involved
yes and on one side uh you have the the
sort of human drama of it all and it's
it's it's hard not to be shocked at the
distance and speed and depth of the Fall
From Grace on the other hand you have a
a multi-million pound company that is a
public company
um that has a share price and
shareholders and that employs thousands
and thousands of people being directly
affected by this because it's it's
breakfast programming is is it sort of
Mainstay and so you have those two
things playing off against each other
and yes I agree with Katie I think this
is schofield's attempt to begin to fight
back a little bit to begin and put his
own narrative out there I mean who knows
what has happened uh between two people
behind closed doors but uh what is
becoming increasingly difficult to
believe is that no one around them knew
anything and that you know they managed
to mislead
um everyone from the their closest
friends and colleagues to
um their managers and so I think that is
what ITV in its own part is trying to
manage yes and we're starting to hear
from other people involved Holly
Willoughby and one of the other papers
saying that she's nothing to hide also
that the male has spoken to Phillip
schofield's wife and then she um
reportedly is furious Katie
or you would expect her to be furious
um really if the reports are correct
that she didn't know about this her
husband um led her to believe that there
was nothing untoward
um this man was a friend and a colleague
nothing more than that and there's also
a detail in there I think in that report
I'm saying that his daughter only found
uh really moments before this became a
public story so um while we're obviously
talking about the corporate consequences
um there's clearly um you know a family
being torn apart potentially by by
um The Story by what Philip Schofield is
admitting to
um and I think that it's interesting in
terms of the Hollywood you have sources
close to her saying she has nothing to
hide in this interview and we've all so
far seen Snippets of it from the front
page and from the write-ups he also
seems to be apologizing to his co-host
for
um which seems to corroborate Holly
willoughby's account which was that she
asked her colleague about this and she
was told nothing was happening and of
course that that plays into
um will she returned to the sofa because
there's been some figures
um saying actually surely she must have
known something she shouldn't and I
think this probably is um
adding to the argument that she isn't a
place to do that unless something else
comes forward Alex let's move on to
another story this um in the guardian uh
the first one we can take a look at and
how they're covering it and this is the
ministers launching um an attempt not to
hand over WhatsApp messages to the
covert inquiry Boris Johnson's WhatsApp
messages
I mean this is extraordinary there's no
other way to describe it this is in
summary uh the government taking an
inquiry that it's set up and gave powers
to to court because it's saying it's
overstay stepping those powers that it
gave it and so it it it's an
extraordinary struggle even on the
basics of it but then the politics come
into it and that make it 10 times more
scintillating because what you have is
for many many days uh the the number 10
and cabinet office we're briefing that
it was really they were trying to
protect Boris Johnson until Boris
Johnson basically lobbed the grenade at
that yesterday by coming out and saying
I'm perfectly happy for everything to be
published in fact I will give it to the
inquiry directly if you don't
um and that really set the cat amongst
the pigeons so the cabinet office then
had only two options to either comply
with a deadline or to go to court and
seek judicial review and there is a
supreme irony to what they're doing in
that they're invoking the Human Rights
Act which up until really a couple of
months ago it was this government's
policy to repeal that act and not only
are they invoking that act they're
invoking powers that flow from article
late of the European Convention of human
rights which is the one they constantly
say is causing them huge amounts of
trouble when Lefty lawyers are using it
to obstruct what the state wants to do
and there they are now they have found
their own Lefty lawyers and they're
taking effectively another expression of
the state that they created to court in
order to avoid handing over this stuff I
mean it it is simply extraordinary and
Katie the the
[Music]
um
criticism leveled often is that you know
if you've nothing to hide why don't you
want these these messages really put in
the public domain
yeah I mean there are so many angles to
this story and what's happening at the
moment
um of course yes if you've got nothing
to hide publish them uh the fact that
Boris Jones is saying something
different from the government and I
don't think he's perhaps being so
helpful the Curiosity he hasn't actually
he's saying he's happy to give these
messages to inquiry he's yet to do so
and some of his messages aren't
available but I think we'll come on to
that later
um but yes is it is it because they have
something to hide or is there precedent
I think that is this is all right now
about Boris Johnson but of course the
problem for the government is if they
allow these messages unredacted so the
Masters doesn't build to go to the
inquiry and they may have to do that if
the judicial review is not successful
and it sets a precedent for serving
ministers including the prime minister
of united to do the same so I think you
can start to see a world where there's
going to be lots of messages and they
would argue that these are not
specifically related to the covert
inquiry so why put them out there but I
think um you could enter a scenario
where uh ultimately this this current
Saga creates a press tomorrow which
every serving Minister who had a role in
the pandemic is having to hand over all
the messages to this inquiry and it is
quite um a strange thing in the way that
the government is now almost suing its
own inquiry seems to be where we've got
to so early on in the entire process
um often these inquiries can be called
whitewashers
um too soft I don't think there seems to
be a problem with uh how the code
inquiry is shaping up I think it looks
like it's really gonna um you know hold
the fee to the government to the fire
the eye pointing to the fact Alex that
Boris Johnson hasn't handed over his own
messages covering the first year of
covid-19 and he claims that Security
Services told him not to turn on his old
personal mobile phone because it
contains whatsapps from before May 2021
um and that's after the number became
available online so it's because of
security
yes I remember that story from the time
actually in the furthest reaches of my
memory so much has happened since
um of course Johnson is now offering to
make those messages available provided
basically the right tech support come to
to turn on his phone to make sure that
it's not a security threat but there's a
the really interesting angle of this and
uh Katie referred to it there in her
summary is that the government is
treating this as if they're giving this
stuff over for publication they're not
they're handing this stuff to a senior
judge that they appointed and she will
be the judge of whether to publish it or
not so if there's something in there
that is completely private and entirely
relevant I think it's extraordinary to
express the the notion that they can't
trust the very senior judge that they
appointed to not publish that and so the
the whole thing is being fought as if
handing this stuff over will mean its
immediate publication in all the papers
and that's just not the case they're
handing it over to the judge whose
primary duties to look over all this
stuff and judge what is in the public
interest and what is relevant and what
is not and I think she's quite right to
claim that they can't make that
determination for her they can't
pre-decide what is relevant and just
pass that stuff along and I I see the
prospects of success for the government
in the judicial reviewers very very low
yes in Casey vft
um pointing to the cabinet office their
argument is that the request for
unambiguously irrelevant material goes
beyond the powers of the inquiry and
they're not wanting a precedent to be
set in this respect
yes and of course I think that that
point is completely correct which is
this stuff isn't uh these messages
wouldn't be immediately made public
um but clearly there's a concern in
government the president of handing them
over even to a judge
um an independent inquiry
um and then putting them out there when
uh they think they're just so clearly
irrelevant now one of the arguments is
uh it could show that the focus in
government was not where it needed to be
uh because these messages show where
other things were
um but then you also want you know a
lack of attendance of Boris Johnson at
various Cobra meetings which is one of
the questions that we believe um the the
judge who is in charge of the inquiry
just had it is asking about also point
to that as is so so I do think it's um
is tricky in a sense
I think right now without knowing what
exactly the messages are on all these
things to know how relevant or how much
of an intrusion these things are
um but it does feel as though lots of
legal experts tonight are saying that
they do not think the government has a
very good chance in the judicial review
so we may end up in a scenario where
um it ultimately they have to do so
anyway